- Her new album is called
A Very Trainor Christmas,
and it drops October 30th.
Please give it up for Meghan Trainor!
(upbeat electronic music)
(crowd cheering)
We love you!
- Hi, y'all.
- I would've dressed up
with you is the thing.
- Girl, this is my promo looks
every single day.
- You could sit down.
Our COVID seating.
First of all, I have those leggings.
- I know!
- How good are these?
They're so awesome.
You look so great.
- I'm so cozy,
and I'm pregnant.
- [Kelly] I know, that's exciting.
- I did it, thank you.
- I did it, is it like,
has it been hard or has
it been kind of okay?
- It's been like spooky,
I guess is the best word.
Just 'cause like I don't leave the house
'cause I'm terrified.
- Oh, oh.
- Right.
And then all my doctors
appointments I'm like alone.
So I like, 'cause you can't
bring your husband in.
So I have to do everything
and film everything myself
and like--
- Oh, that sucks.
- [Meghan] Sucks, but it's all right.
We'll figure it out.
- Well, FaceTime.
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, FaceTime.
- Not the same, yeah.
- No, I videotape.
- Yeah, I was trying to
find the silver lining
in that crap situation.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so what did you
do to keep yourself busy
during quarantine?
- I planned this.
So this was like--
- You planned it.
= Oh yeah, I was like doing the tests
and like tracking with all the apps.
I like was like we're gonna get this done.
We're going to do it.
- I love it.
- I was so excited, so
that was a mission, and--
- Kind of great timing
for artists or activists
because you can't work anyway.
- That was my sign.
I was like, "We're stuck here.
"Let's let's do the thing
we always wanted to do,
"is make a baby."
(crowd laughing)
So we did that, and then
I did a Christmas album
'cause I was home with my
studio, and my brothers,
they're like, they produce
and wrote half these songs
with me, all the originals, so--
- Really?
- Yes, it was awesome.
It was a fun time.
So all my early weird pregnancy feelings,
I was singing this whole Christmas album.
- That's, so this wasn't
the plan to do Christmas.
It just was kinda like,
hey, this is perfect timing.
That's actually awesome.
- That's always been the dream
because like I am Christmas.
My birthday is December 22nd.
My wedding was on that day as well.
- Your birthday gets trumped
every year anyway, oh.
No, no, it gets better.
- Just a big celebration?
- Yeah, like I always have my
anniversary on my birthday.
So it's like--
- You're so happy right now.
- I'm so happy, I'm glowing.
- [Kelly] I know, that's really cool.
I'm so happy for you.
- Thank you, thank you.
Thanks.
- That's so awesome.
Well congrats.
I hear that you're
obviously gonna be a mom,
but have you thought of
what songs that you'll sing?
I do have a song.
I can't believe I'm gonna
say this the first time ever,
with Earth, Wind and Fire.
- What?
- On my Christmas album.
- Oh my gosh!
- And we just had--
- They should let, this is a great tease.
- I know, right?
I was like, I'm allowed to say it.
The track listing will be out I think.
So we did a music video and I was like
my baby's first music video
is with Earth, Wind, and Fire.
- Oh my gosh, that's incredible!
- Thank you.
I'm sweating, I don't know
if I'm allowed to say that.
- The bar high, though.
- The bar is high.
- You're setting the bar high.
- Oops.
- Oops, all right.
Well suit yourselves.
Is it true that you run your
songs by your Uber drivers?
- What, how do you know that?
- We have really good
Intel, and here's the thing.
I actually think that's awesome.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I love, before corona,
I haven't taken a Uber
in so long, but before
corona, I would like
at my hair salon, at
everywhere, I'd be like,
"Stranger, come here, what
do you think about this?"
And I study people's body language.
Like if I lose them in the
first like verse and chorus,
I'm like, (scoffing) "Got to fix it."
Or Uber drivers were like,
"This is great, who is she?"
And I'd be like, "She's a superstar."
Like,
- Oh, so you don't say,
they don't know who you are.
- No, they have no idea.
- Oh, that's amazing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm purely testing them on
like, do you like this or not?
- What's a piece of Uber driver feedback
that you can recall?
- I mean one guy who was
just like, "This is so good.
"Will you send it to me?"
And I was like, "No, this is like,"
and then I had to explain why.
And then he was like, "No way!"
And I was like, "Yeah!"
- And then he was probably
like, "Glad I liked it."
- Yeah, right?
And yeah, I've never
had anyone be like, mm,
which is thank God,
but yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
Her new album is called
A Very Trainor Christmas.
It drops October 30th.
You got to get it or you're dumb.
I'm just kidding.
But you get it.
It'll make you feel good.
Congrats on the Christmas record.
I love Christmas.
I know you love Christmas.
I can see i right now.
So are you as big of a nerd?
We were talking in the break.
Are you as big of a nerd
about Christmas as I am?
- Yeah.
- I'm like Chevy Chase level decorating.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my house is fully decorated.
Look, that's our life.
- Oh my gosh.
- Those are our real pajamas.
- I get the same thing.
We do the same thing and all we--
- We should do it together.
- Oh my gosh, we should
have like a war of like,
who can come up with the
funniest Christmas card.
Why did I make it a competition?
- It's on.
- So weird.
- I live for that day, for
those that Christmas week.
That's my everything.
- Oh, that's so great.
So what was your favorite
Christmas song as a kid?
'Cause there's so many.
- There are so many.
- Yeah.
- I really, I really loved
Michael Buble's White Christmas
- Yeah!
- It was good.
I love all your Christmas stuff.
We did a Christmas show together.
- [Kelly] We did.
- I totally forgot that
until this moment right now.
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
until you said that I
literally went back in my brain
and went, "Mmhm, yup."
and I was like, (laughing)
- I don't, like yeah.
- And I'm not pregnant.
- We did a Christmas show
together in like Nashville?
- Yep, that was when
people could go to shows.
- Yes.
- Yeah, and we were
in the arena at Bridgestone.
That was sad that we can't do that now.
That's so right, I love you.
So you had some help, you said,
putting this record together
right?
- Yes, I did.
- Your whole family pitched in.
Was everyone in the picture?
- Big songwriters.
Big producers.
Yes, it was my older brother
and my younger brother
and my husband, and my family
was my background singers
'cause those are the only human
beings I saw in that time.
And we were all like very
clean, very protective.
My dad's on the older side
of things and I was pregnant.
So none, my brothers like
never left the house for me.
And like getting groceries is very hard,
but we did it very safely.
And my husband would dress up and shower.
So yeah.
- Well, speaking
of your hubby what's up
guys, how y'all doing?
(crowd cheering)
(indistinct)
- [Meghan] Kelly Clarkson!
- I love that y'all are in
front of a Christmas tree.
So all right guys, first congrats
on being a new dad and uncle.
That's exciting.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh, they're so sweet.
- I'm a funcle.
- He's a funkle.
- A funcle?
I was like, "Wait what?"
You can't say that on daytime.
So how did you break the news to everyone?
How did y'all...
- Oh, well they saw me as
soon as I peed on the stick.
I ran out and like videotaped.
I was just shaking and
was like, "I did it!"
'cause the whole house knew.
I didn't want it to be that big
of a surprise for the house.
I was like, "Just so y'all know,
"we're doing science over here.
"So heads up.
"Don't be surprised when
I come out with a stick."
So when I did that they were like,
"What is it, your pregnancy test?"
And I was like, "Yeah!"
- Oh my gosh, I love that.
- That's how we did that.
- I mean, but that's really fun though.
Everybody's quarantine sucked.
That would've been awesome
to be in a fun house.
You're so half glass full.
I love you.
So I forgot to ask though,
do you know the gender of the baby yet?
- We've never told anyone, so I'm gonna--
- You haven't told, you--
- No, I saved it for you,
Kelly, I love you!
- Oh my gosh!
Are you excited?
Was it what you thought I
went you were pregnant with?
- No, because I did all
those, they're so excited.
I did all those like look
online of like how big,
how fast the heartbeat?
Where do your hips go?
And I was like, "Oh, it must be this."
I was wrong.
- Oh my gosh.
- Okay, they're gonna tell you
'cause they never get to tell anyone.
- It's a boy!
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my gosh, it's so exciting!
Oh my God!
This is the first time
you're telling people?
- Anybody, I'm so sweaty.
- Oh my gosh, it's so exciting.
Have you already bought stuff?
- No!
- What?
- Because I was like, "I don't know, I'm,"
oh, I can't say how long I am.
I don't know, I'm just over halfway.
- You're just nervous--
- Yeah and then people
want to buy me stuff and I'm like,
"Well do I want to have two cribs?"
Like what do I do?
Help me.
- Oh, I am so opposite of you.
I literally found out I was pregnant
and the whole room is decorated
by Tuesday.
- I want to.
So okay, I'm going tonight,
I'm doing it tonight.
Let's go.
- I love,
I love all of that stuff though.
Well, how, Darryl and Ryan,
how did you guys pitch in
on the Christmas record,
by the way?
- Oh man, I'm the cheerleader.
I bring the waters, make
sure everyone's hydrated,
and then sometimes I sing backgrounds.
- He's a good background singer.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, I'm just a vibe guy.
Meghan will say a lyric.
I say that's great.
I'm really just a fraud.
I'm just in the room.
- He came up
with all the lyrics.
He's very shy and sweet.
- Ah, you're humble!
- He's my cool guy.
He is humble.
- You're like,
you're playing yourself
like you're the hype guy and
you're writing the lyrics.
- He's like, "I'm not doing anything."
I was like, "You're a song writer.
"You're just naturally good at it.
"It's easy for you."
- [Kelly] Oh, how fun is that
to be with your family?
- It's so nice.
It's so good.
I'm trying to get him a plug deal.
Anyone looking out, he's a song writer,
and he also was conducting my vocals.
- That's good.
This is the secret.
My sister's like that.
When I have a studio, she
was like, it was, yeah.
And then she'll be like, "This is amazing.
"Don't screw it up.
"Don't let them over produce it."
- Okay, yeah, family.
- Well, so Meghan and Ryan.
So you were always best
friends as a family.
And I think that we have
the video to prove it.
Let's see.
- [Dad] Didn't I say don't bug him?
- I won't bug him!
- Well you just ran into him didn't ya?
- Don't talk to me.
I'm gonna be his best friend
and not your best friend.
- I like daddy.
I'm his best friend.
- I'm your best friend too!
I'm sassy.
- That's literally you
guys, when you were kids.
- Yeah, I really wanted to be best friends
with my brother and my dad.
And it was like always a competition.
Who's best friends?
- Y'all need you to write
a Christmas Hallmark movie
with Christmas songs and do
the whole thing together.
as a family.
- I'm down.
- I would watch and listen to this.
That was adorable.
All right, well it's time for a break.
Everyone go get the new album,
A Very Trainor Christmas.
It comes out October 30th.
Congratulations, it's a boy!
- It's a boy!